[Musique]
bonjour à toutes bonjour à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 pour une
nouvelle émission aujourd'hui comme vous
le voyez on se retrouve une nouvelle
fois au Vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pour
l'événement ski hit l'événement des
innovations et des talents de
l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines nous sommes le
jeudi 20 avril voici le programme
d'aujourd'hui
à l'approche des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de Paris 2024 qui eat
permet aux entreprises de se rencontrer
et de créer une dynamique sur le
territoire de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
après une journée dédiée à l'emploi hier
aujourd'hui l'événement se consacre aux
professionnels et aux innovations
intelligence artificielle cybersécurité
autant de thèmes qui ont été abordés
dans la journée on en parle avec nos
invités Alexandra Rosetti vice-président
délégué au développement économique et à
l'attractivité du territoire pour
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et Nadia
Benallal délégué général de French tech
Paris Saclay et puis comme d'habitude le
jeudi à l'approche du week-end et des
vacances scolaires nous vous donnerons
nos idées de sortie dans les Yvelines au
programme exposition spectacle mais
aussi une enquête au parc France
Miniature d'Élancourt êtes-vous prêt à
affronter des fantômes et des monstres
issus de nos légendes françaises les
détails avec notre journaliste Gabriel
Gontier adepte des cascades en tout
genre ce stage est peut-être fait pour
vous le Cabaret du bout des prés situés
à Cernay-la-Ville propose des journées
pour s'initier aux cascades de films
vous apprendrez notamment à tomber sans
vous faire mal ça peut être utile après
avoir proposé cette activité lors des
vacances de février au plus jeune le
cabaret ouvre ses coulisses aux
entreprises les précisions dans cette
émission avec Mélanie poquet et Julien
Leroy et justement un plateau avec moi
Alexandra Rosetti bonjour bonjour Alors
je le répète vous êtes la vice-pré
déléguer en charge du développement
économique et de l'attractivité du
territoire pour l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines alors comment
ça se passe cette seconde journée du ski
it ça se passe très bien comme vous
pouvez voir le vélo de route et plein
donc on est vraiment ravis on a cueille
quelques 500 entreprises aujourd'hui
avec des rendez-vous
d'échanges quand même ce matin il y
avait 2000 rendez-vous confirmés ce qui
est vraiment considérable et puis sans
oublier tout ce qui se passe dans la
journée de rendez-vous informel et selon
nos enquêtes habituelles en général
c'est à peu près le même nombre donc on
n'a pas encore bien sûr tous les
chiffres puisque la journée se termine
mais je pense qu'on va être sur 4000
mise en relation quel est l'objectif de
cette journée justement vous venez de le
dire rapprocher des entreprises créer
des opportunités voilà créer des
opportunités de business puisque c'est
en fait ces deux journées c'est je
rappelle c'était le avant le en piste
pour l'emploi qui se faisait une période
plus le Sky business d a un autre une
autre période et donc on a fait le choix
de tout rassembler sur ces deux jours et
on voit que la formule fonctionne
vraiment très bien avec aussi comme
nouveauté donc il y a bien ses remises
en relation bien sûr les stands des
entreprises qui sont là et ce sont des
entreprises
importantes pour notre territoire
évidemment et puis également des
conférences on a on avait huit
conférences aujourd'hui sur des
thématiques assez variées qui répondent
aux enjeux du territoire qu'on va dont
on va peut-être parler après l'occasion
d'en parler un peu plus tard dans cette
émission avec nous également pour parler
de cet événement Nadia Benalal bonjour
bonjour Alors je le répète aussi vous
êtes la déléguée générale de French tech
Paris Saclay alors French tech Paris
Saclay c'est le mouvement français des
startups si je traduis un petit peu en
français il s'agit d'un écosystème qui
réunit des jeunes entreprises des
investisseurs des décideurs comment ça
fonctionne concrètement Nadia alors
effectivement la french Tech est une
initiative du gouvernement il faut
l'avoir en tête puisque ça ça va vous
permettre aussi de comprendre quelle est
notre force de frappe à l'échelle
territoriale il s'agit d'un maillage
donc il existe plusieurs French tech
partout dans le monde il y en a bien
entendu en France nous on représente la
french tech de Paris sacrée et on couvre
principalement le 708 et le 91 notre
rôle est un rôle de facilitation donc on
aide les startups déjà de se rencontrer
entre elles pour pouvoir échanger sur
leur retour d'expérience mais également
de les mettre en relation avec tous
types d'acteurs qui pourraient les aider
dans le développement de leur activité
ça peut être des acteurs
issus du service public par exemple ça
peut être également des relations avec
des laboratoires ou tout type de
compétences qu'il existe sur le
territoire ça peut être des relations
avec des grands comptes des entreprises
qu'on retrouve ici aujourd'hui à skit
oui effectivement on a un stand de très
coloré je pense que ça attire un peu
l'oeil notre rôle c'est aussi de la
culture et les gens puisque beaucoup de
personnes entendent sûrement le terme
French tech en tout cas pour les
personnes qui constituent ou qui font
partie d'un écosystème économique mais
ça reste assez nébuleux on sait jamais
ce qui a derrière une french tech est-ce
que c'est des programmes est-ce que
c'est de l'argent donc effectivement
notre rôle c'est aussi de sensibiliser
un peu mieux ses acteurs et de leur
permettre de mieux comprendre nos
activités et avec nous un plateau un
troisième invité Nicolas Régnier bonjour
bonjour alors vous êtes exécutif Finance
Manager pour exécutif manager final
j'étais dans exactement pour incube
alliance Paris Saclay vous faites partie
du ski cube qu'est-ce que c'est le ski
cube alors le ski cube c'est
l'incubateur de 50 ans en Yvelines qui a
été initié en 2017 et qui vise à
accompagner les projets innovants du
territoire
et avec nous également une journaliste
de la rédaction de TV 78 c'est bonjour
bonjour Mathilde avec vous on va voir
dans quelques instants les informations
du jour dans les Yvelines et ce sera
dans quelques instants restez bien avec
nous dans cette émission également le
traditionnel quiz du jeudi sur quel
thème Grégory canalet va nous challenger
ce soir restez bien avec nous pour le
savoir mais juste avant je vous propose
de jeter un coup d'œil à la météo de
demain
du côté de Rambouillet et de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines nous devrions
avoir quelques éclaircies selon Météo
France au niveau des températures il
fera encore un peu frais le matin
comptez 6 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie et
Versailles 5 degrés à Rambouillet et 4
degrés à ou dans l'après-midi le ciel
s'éclaircit sur l'ensemble du
département et côté température comptait
environ 13 à 12 degrés en moyenne et
demain nous fêterons la saint en scène
le point maintenant sur les informations
du jour dans les Yvelines
et donc c'est avec vous Céline Charles
on commence par cette information
l'agence régionale de santé redemande de
ne plus consommer de issus de poulailler
domestiques situés en Île-de-France oui
tout à fait Mathilde d'après des
analyses menées sur 25 poulailler de la
région francilienne plusieurs polluants
ont été découverts dans les prélèvements
et à des niveaux parfois très élevés des
contaminations qui sont observées sur
l'ensemble de la région et qui peuvent
être dangereuse pour la santé si
consommer à long terme l'origine n'est
pour l'instant pas connu mais là il
reste conseil à titre conservatoire et
par prudence de ne plus consommer de ni
produits animaux de provenance
domestique non contrôlés autre
information Céline les épiceries
sociales de la Croix-Rouge basée à
Élancourt et à Trappes risque la
fermeture la raison Mathilde c'est le
manque de bénévole l'unité locale de
l'association basée à Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines envisage le pire pour ses deux
épiceries son président Denis largetto a
confié à nos confrères du Parisien ne
pouvoir compter que sur une douzaine de
personnes actives pour 187 adhérents
référencé ces épiceries qui récupèrent
des produits dans les supermarchés pour
les redistribuer ensuite au foyer les
plus modestes n'arrivent plus à tourner
correctement d'autant plus que les dons
d'aliments et de vêtements également
chutés à L2 les structures permettent
pourtant à plus d'un millier de foyers
du territoire de bénéficier d'une aide
alimentaire un peu de sport à présent ça
tombe bien on est au Vélodrome national
de 50 ans en Yvelines la nouvelle a été
annoncée ce jeudi le marathon pour tous
des olympique de Paris aura lieu en
nocturne et oui et le départ est prévu à
21h du parvis de l'Hôtel de Ville de
Paris les coureurs selon seront jusqu'à
Versailles pour rejoindre ensuite les
Invalides pour rappel le marathon pour
tous propose à 24024 athlètes amateurs
d'emprunter le même parcours que le
marathon olympique une course de 10 km
est également proposée pour 24024
coureurs supplémentaires l'objectif est
de faire vivre au plus grand nombre de
personnes l'expérience des jeux les
coureurs selon seront donc de nuit le 10
août 2024 une décision prise pour
limiter les risques liés à la chaleur
demain la zone C entre en vacances
scolaires des perturbations sont donc à
attendre sur les routes c'est OUI à
chaque départ de vacances au lot de
perturbations sur les routes selon Bison
Futé les principales difficultés
attendues en Île-de-France sont dans le
sens des départs vendredi et samedi
vendredi l'Île-de-France est classé
orange il vous est conseillé de quitter
ou traverser la région avant 14h des
difficultés de circulation sont à
prévoir en direction des barrières de
péage de l'autoroute A10
samedi la circulation sera dense
également il est préférable de prévoir
un départ de la région avant 8h merci
beaucoup Céline char pour toutes ces
informations et comme d'habitude si vous
aussi vous voyez une image ou une
information qui vous a marqué près de
chez vous n'hésitez pas à nous la
partager en utilisant le hashtag 7 8
news
et nous sommes toujours bien installés
au Vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines à l'occasion
de l'événement ski hit le rendez-vous
des talents et des innovations et on
vient d'être Jean par une nouvelle
journée de la rédaction de TV 78 Régine
rage bonjour bonjour Alors on revient
avec vous sur cette seconde journée
consacrée aux entreprises et aux
innovations qu'avez-vous trouvé
d'intéressant aujourd'hui régime
tout comme hier la journée était axée
sur la tech il y a de nombreuses
conférences notamment ce matin sur
l'intelligence artificielle et la
cybersécurité et alors
pouvez-vous nous en dire un peu plus oui
tout à fait alors donc j'ai assisté à
cette conférence sur l'intelligence
artificielle qui est au service de la
compétitivité des entreprises et les
intervenants ont donné leurs astuces
pour utiliser au mieux ces technologies
et les rendre plus facilement
compréhensibles pour l'ensemble des
équipes et puis tout juste après donc
c'était la conférence sur la cyber
sécurité excusez-moi plusieurs
entreprises sont montées sur scène pour
pitcher leur activité en 6 minutes et
d'ailleurs c'était le cas de la société
X playo qui est basé à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux elle miraïs
incolaborateur de l'entreprise explique
que les cyberata qui ont plus que
doubler ces dernières années et ce n'est
plus qu'une question de science-fiction
mais de réalité selon ses propos il y
avait aussi un pôle business it c'est la
convention d'affaires du skate tout à
fait les entreprises avaient quand elles
20 minutes pour échanger se rencontrer
et créer des synergies et je suis parti
à leur rencontre écoutez les réactions
c'est vraiment on attend les visiteurs
on essaie de découvrir aussi les autres
acteurs du territoire donc c'est à la
fois pour nous les visiteurs qui
viennent sur notre stand et puis faire
le tour aussi de toutes les tous les
exposants pour faire connaissance je
suis venu aujourd'hui essentiellement
pour
rencontrer les acteurs locaux de
l'économie locale pour développer
mon réseau pour voir s'il y a pas des
opportunités professionnelles des
nouvelles rencontres surtout créer une
nouvelle synergie
aussi également voir ce qui se fait en
terme d'innovation
et pour terminer sur un côté un peu plus
léger dans le salon il y avait également
un corner sport l'occasion pour les
entreprises de se renseigner sur l'accès
au marché des jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de Paris 2024 le tout en
participant à des animations sportives
telles que du Golfe du vélo ou du
picpong en virtuel vous avez pu les
tester Régine ou pas je les ai pas testé
mais j'ai qu'une hâte c'est d'y aller et
vois Alexandra Rosetti Nadia Benallal
vous les avez testé
moi j'ai testé le golf et puis le ce que
le Pôle Emploi mis en place aussi pour
les jobs de autour des JO voilà qui
permettent de voir un petit peu quelles
sont nos soft skills et nos compétences
pour pouvoir postuler
voilà
et vous Nicolas rédier est-ce que vous
avez pu tester les petites animations
sport pas encore mais ça ne serait tardé
merci beaucoup en tout cas Régine rallès
pour toutes ces informations on continue
de parler de cet événement avec nos
trois invités alors cette journée elle
est consacrée aux entreprises et aux
innovations Alexandra Rosetti qu'est-ce
qui fait du territoire de Saint-Quentin
en Yvelines une terre d'innovation
alors c'est nos entreprises justement
qui innovent dans beaucoup de domaines
bon on a un territoire où il y a un très
grand nombre d'entreprises il y a 17000
entreprises 145 000 emplois donc
forcément on est vraiment au coeur avec
des grands comptes avec des TPE des PME
et on est vraiment au cœur de
l'innovation sur beaucoup de sujets et
en particulier on a parlé de
cybersécurité par exemple on c'est un
vrai sujet qui nous intéresse et dans
notre dans notre incubateur et
effectivement on a aussi on reçoit de
plus en plus de startups qui se tournent
vers l'innovation vous avez le sentiment
que l'attractivité du territoire
aujourd'hui est toujours aussi forte
malgré le contexte économique un peu
plus compliqué oui je crois que notre
agglomération reste une agglomération
extrêmement dynamique et même puissante
économiquement et puis on fait tout pour
être attractif alors il y a des
événements comme celui-ci qui bien sûr
rayonne bien au-delà de Saint-Quentin on
s'est on avait reçu le Big tour l'année
dernière où on s'était aussi beaucoup
impliqué et notre effectivement notre
attractivité elle repose aussi sur
l'accompagnement qu'on fait de nos
entreprises en particulier dans la façon
dont elles veulent se des fois se
réorganiser s'implanter à des endroits
différents on voit souvent des
entreprises qui peut-être ont des locaux
un peu trop grand avec la les nouvelles
les nouveaux modes de travail et donc il
y a un service qui accompagne les
entreprises sur l'immobilier
d'entreprise et par exemple aujourd'hui
nous avions un rendez-vous avec les
acteurs de l'immobilier ce matin où on a
pu mettre en valeur tout le travail qui
a été fait sur l'hypercentre de Montigny
qui accueille des immeubles flambant
neufs qui ont été soit démolir
reconstruits soit
réadapter et qui accueille des modes de
travail un peu différents je pense à un
bâtiment en particulier qui va qui va
ouvrir qui accueille des mètres carrés
d'entreprises mais également du coliving
par exemple on a un autre bâtiment où on
va avoir de l'entreprise adossé à un
immeuble de d'habitation voilà donc on
essaye vraiment maintenant de de mixer
les différents modes de travail aussi
je crois qu'il faut que les salariés qui
viennent sur site trouvent aussi autre
chose que des lieux de travail mais
aussi des lieux d'épanouissement ils
peuvent faire du sport manger voilà donc
tout tout ça Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
l'accompagne de façon vraiment très
précise et je pense que ça participe à
notre attractivité donc pour accompagner
ces entreprises il y a aussi cet
événement ce qui est alors au programme
de cette seconde journée des
démonstrations des conférences vous en
parlez un petit peu en début d'émission
c'est des moments essentiels pour créer
du lien et des opportunités entre les
entreprises
oui je pense que les résultats d'abord
qu'on obtient depuis quelques années
parce que c'est pas la première fois
qu'on organise ce type d'événement mais
ça me semble essentiel que les
entreprises puissent échanger je pense à
un exemple en particulier
maintenant la nécessité de la le RSE
on a des entreprises qui sont
intéressées pour rencontrer des
opérateurs qui vont sur la
responsabilité enfin sur les achats
responsables par exemple il y a un
corner dédié à ça donc ça nous permet
voilà de mettre en contact des gens en
fonction des nouveaux des nouveaux
besoins qui qui peuvent qui peuvent
émerger Nadia Benalal vous avez pu
assister à certains rendez-vous
d'aujourd'hui et qu'est-ce que vous en
avez pensé oui alors effectivement ce
qu'on a retenu c'est la diversité
d'acteurs c'est le rôle d'un lieu comme
celui-ci de confronter différents mondes
qui parfois ne se rencontrent pas en
tout cas dans la vie de tous les jours
en une fois rapidement on sait que le
temps confronté de ces personnes et donc
d'avoir ces différents profils dans un
même lieu ça permet de faciliter ces
échanges et puis aussi encore une fois
comme je vous disais tout à l'heure la
première question qu'on nous pose nous à
notre stand mais c'est quoi la french
tech donc ça permet également d'activer
un peu mieux sur cette marque French
tech on voit et qu'on entend mais qu'on
pour le coup on comprend pas vraiment de
quoi il s'agit on est aussi là pour les
sensibiliser permet de vous faire
connaître exactement Nicolas Régnier je
me tourne vers vous vous aussi ça vous a
permis de créer des opportunités cette
journée oui pas uniquement pour les
entrepreneurs parce que j'ai rencontré
une dizaine de rendez-vous qualifiés que
j'aurais pas pu organiser dans mon
quotidien donc c'est vraiment un moment
unique où on peut rencontrer à la fois
des prospects à la fois des partenaires
des prestataires etc et c'est et c'est
ça aussi la la vie d'un entrepreneur
c'est de pouvoir aussi profiter de
l'événement comme ça pour
tout simplement échanger progresser et
puis aller à leur rencontre de ses
clients et ça c'est très important
est-ce que ce type d'événement ça vous
permet de repérer des talents
des talents oui après peut-être au-delà
des talents c'est des personnalités
c'est des nouvelles visions des
nouvelles personnes tout simplement en
fait et qu'est-ce qui fait un talent
aujourd'hui selon vous
je m'attendais pas à cette question là
je pense que au monde d'aujourd'hui
enfin et la façon c'est un talent c'est
une personne qui pense peut-être
différemment aujourd'hui qui est capable
de penser au-delà du prêt-à-penser
habituel et qui est capable de se
projeter dans un avenir
plus écologique
plus respectueux des êtres humains etc
et ça pour le coup pour moi c'est un
vrai talent alors le coeur de cet
événement Alexandra Rosetti c'est aussi
de favoriser les échanges entre les plus
grandes entreprises du territoire et
puis les plus jeunes entreprises qui qui
débutent à peine oui et je remercie la
présence de nos entreprises de nos
filières stratégiques puisque on a quand
même quelques belles filières sur
Saint-Quentin l'aéronautique la défense
la mobilité la santé donc ça permet
effectivement à tout le monde de se
rencontrer je fais un petit aparté sur
les talents puisque je rappelle que hier
on a mis en valeur les talentueuses
c'est à dire les les femmes qui osent et
qui se lancent dans des métiers souvent
plus masculin comme les métiers du
numérique en particulier donc je refais
un petit petit appel là-dessus parce que
c'était vraiment très intéressant
c'est primordial aujourd'hui à Alexandra
Rosetti d'avoir des notions en termes de
cybersécurité bah oui je crois qu'on l'a
dit tout à l'heure effectivement les
cyberattaques évidemment ce multiplient
et justement comme nous avons nous les
les filières importantes de la de la
défense par exemple qui sont sur
Saint-Quentin et ben forcément la
cybersécurité c'est un sujet qui nous
intéresse et on essaie de favoriser
l'implantation par exemple on a favorisé
l'implantation de l'école 2600 parce
qu'on sait qu'aussi il y a un sujet de
recrutement pour les entreprises dans 6
filières là donc Saint-Quentin aussi qui
forme nos futurs métiers liés à la
cybersécurité voilà tout à fait donc
c'est important pour nous aussi
d'accompagner aussi les entreprises dans
leur dans leur recherche de
enfin dans leur recrutement parce que
c'est un domaine vraiment qui est devenu
incontournable
vous êtes un peu d'accord avec ce qu'on
vient de dire la cybersécurité
aujourd'hui c'est
mondial pour se prémunir des
cyberattaques qui comme le disait Régine
il y a quelques instants on doubler
alors oui tout à fait on peut le
ressentir avec l'actualité posz covid
mais également les tensions
géopolitiques qui ont ramené certains
gouvernements à revoir leur stratégie en
termes d'innovation la cyber sécurité en
fait partie on le ressent plus
concrètement avec des plantes
financement et je préciserai plutôt ce
plan appelé France 2030 qui donne
l'opportunité à des entreprises à des
chercheurs de pouvoir développer des
technologies dans ces dans ces filières
le rôle de la French Tech est d'ailleurs
de sensibiliser aux appels à candidature
aux appels à manifestation d'intérêt au
fond dédiés ciblés sur ces du coup
différentes nouvelles tendances qu'on
ressent depuis quelques mois maintenant
oui et ça vous a permis d'avoir plus
d'informations sur ce sujet là cette
journée et une conférence sur la
cybersécurité alors effectivement les
conférences du matin ont permis de nous
sensibiliser sur certains points pour
lequel on est pas forcément les
informations
on est aussi sensibilisé par les
entreprises qu'on accompagne voilà la
french tech rassemble maintenant plus de
300 adhérents dont une majorité de
startups dans la santé et une minorité
de start-up orientée sur les enjeux
actuels mais qui vont être que
croissantes étant donné que elles sont
de plus en plus importantes donc on
parle de la cyber sécurité entre autres
mais ça touche également les sujets agro
et Agri cassoulinés tout à l'heure votre
collègue Nicolas Régnier vous avez pu
accompagner des entreprises et des
startups aujourd'hui sur cette question
là alors oui sur la cybersécurité
évidemment même si c'est un sujet qui
touche toutes les start-up en fait même
si vous développez une plateforme qui
s'adresse au lycéen vous êtes forcément
touchés par la cybersécurité parce que
il faut protéger les adhérents
c'est le règlement sur la rgpd qui qui
vous oblige à protéger enfin oui et
c'est et en parlant de cybersécurité
souvent on a aussi tendance à oublier un
petit peu la sécurité physique des
personnes et ça je pense que c'est
important de pas l'oublier et c'est
important d'avoir cette dualité et là
pour le coup je peux citer par exemple
une société qui s'appelle la Core qui a
été accompagnée à ce qui cube et qui
développe des portiques innovants pour
filtrer les personnes de manière fluide
dans les événements comme l'événement
d'aujourd'hui alors un autre thème était
également sur la table aujourd'hui c'est
l'intelligence artificielle elle fait
aussi beaucoup parler d'elle dans
l'actualité pour vous l'intelligence
artificielle c'est devenu essentiel
aussi pour développer une entreprise
alors essentiel peut-être pas parce que
il y a quand même de l'intelligence
humaine derrière toutes les startups
qu'on accompagne il y a 5 ans je disais
que j'allais être remplacé par une
intelligence artificielle et je suis
toujours là donc
à vrai dire oui c'est un sujet
d'actualité
peut-être un peu trop d'actualité et ça
serait peut-être bien de remettre un peu
l'humain au centre
parler des talents tout à l'heure et ça
serait bien de remettre en avant les
talents en fait justement
pour remettre l'humain au centre et un
peu moins l'intelligence artificielle
alors je reprendrai un de ces termes la
dualité je pense que c'est vraiment
important mais effectivement la
culturation aussi au travers que peut
amener l'intelligence artificielle au
plus jeune âge si je puis dire et c'est
d'ailleurs un plan que l'Université de
Paris Saclay entre autres souhaite
intégrer dans ces dans ces formations
auprès de ces jeunes futurs talents et
on l'espère très rapidement pour pouvoir
justement les acculturer aux différents
dangers que peuvent amener
l'intelligence artificielle mais
également assez avantage que ça peut
apporter pour des solutions
technologiques et bien merci à vous
trois d'avoir été avec nous d'avoir
accepté notre invitation et d'avoir
répondu à nos questions alors ce qui est
ça se termine ce soir à 18h30 après
c'est l'after eat il me semble avec la
spring Party qui est organisée par
French tech Paris Saclay d'ailleurs donc
c'est vous Nadia
donc venez nombreux et ça me permet de
faire ma petite transition puisque c'est
l'heure de passer à notre page loisirs
[Musique]
êtes-vous prêts à relever le défi le
parc France Miniature d'Élancourt lance
une nouvelle enquête pour déjouer le
sortilège de la fée Morgan muni de votre
Smartphone vous devrez affronter
croque-mitaine fantôme et monstre issus
de nos légendes françaises une enquête
immersive pour petits et grands dont
nous avons recueilli les premières
réactions regardées on va scanner le QR
code pour le numéro 19 pour découvrir
notre mission armée de votre smartphone
immergez-vous au sein des légendes de
notre hexagone c'est le concept de ce
jeu d'enquête proposé par France
Miniature à Élancourt la fée Morgan
ancienne élève du magicien Merlin a jeté
un sortilège sur tout le pays et pour
semer le chaos et la réveillé les
créatures fantastiques de nos régions la
bête du Gévaudan la Tarasque ou encore
le fantôme de la dame bleue vous devrez
résoudre des problèmes pour retrouver la
quiétude du territoire il y a des
énigmes d'observation des énigmes des
défis mathématiques des défis graphiques
beaucoup de choses qui attendent les
familles les petits comme les grands
d'abord
il faut additionner la hauteur de la
tour à la hauteur de la flèche replonger
dans le monde de l'imaginaire à travers
cette enquête intergénérationnelle le
smartphone permet de visionner du
contenu audio et vidéo nécessaire à la
résolution des énigmes une autre manière
de découvrir le parc France Miniature et
d'apprendre en s'amusant ça devient un
outil un peu pédagogique on véhicule les
histoires on leur explique pas mal de
choses aussi sur les monuments et les
enfants ça les ça les anime un peu plus
parce que des fois ils peuvent être
impatient parce qu'on est on prend le
temps que là il y a un jeu derrière donc
ça emmène une autre dynamique il est
juste magnifique et je trouve que le
fait d'avoir un petit jeu comme ça pour
pour les joueurs pour relever des défis
etc je trouve ça trop canon la France
des légendes sera proposée tout au long
de l'année 2023 Nicolas Flamel l'a fait
Mélusine et Jean lafouce vous attendent
durant les vacances de Pâques pour vous
aider dans votre quête
et nous avons été rejoint un plateau par
de nouveau journaliste de la rédaction
de TV 78 Grégory canalet bonjour bonjour
Mathilde le jeudi vous nous présenter
votre quiz sur quoi est-ce que vous
allez notre challenger et bien je vais
profiter de notre présence ici dans le
vélo drone national qui nous accueille
pour cette émission afin de vous
challenger justement sur le vélo de
route nationale des questions autour de
son histoire des événements qu'il a pu
accueillir les personnes qui ont marqué
aussi l'histoire de ce vélo de route
nationale on va jouer autour de tous ces
thèmes aujourd'hui et bien on va tenter
de répondre à vos questions mais avant
je me tourne vers vous Gabriel Gauthier
bonjour bonjour Mathilde alors vous
aussi comme d'habitude le jeudi vous
présentez vos idées de sortie vos
meilleurs plans pour pour le week-end
mais aussi pour les vacances dans les
Yvelines et ce soir du coup à l'approche
des vacances vous avez un petit peu
élargi oui tout à fait de quoi vous
occupez pendant les vacances on commence
même un peu avant les vacances Mathilde
avec un spectacle dès ce soir alors il
s'intitule Queen Blood et met la danse
hip-hop à l'honneur dans son spectacle
Ousmane si grande figure de la house
propose un spectacle urbain 100% féminin
à travers la danse le spectacle
interroge sur la féminité qu'elle soit
revendiquée ou rejetée sur scène 7
danseuse explosive au style unique afro
house Spirit se joue des codes masculins
pour affirmer leur style sur les
sonorités acoustiques et électro voici
un extrait de leur performance
[Musique]
et le spectacle il est à retrouver ce
soir et demain à 20h30 au Théâtre de 50
ans en Libye direction à présent la
verrière le sport aussi est mis en avant
par l'association Sport Santé bouger
tout à fait vendredi à 19h c'est au
travers d'un débat et d'ateliers
interactif que vous pourrez apprendre
les notions essentielles sur l'activité
physique et le sport vous pourrez ainsi
évaluer votre capital santé ou encore
établir un programme hebdomadaire des
notions utiles quand on sait que en
France près de 73% des hommes et 71% des
femmes de plus de 15 ans pratiquent une
activité physique de manière régulière
selon le baromètre national des
pratiques sportives on poursuit avec une
exposition inédite Gabriel elle se situe
à des fleuris
tout à fait oui unique car il se tient
dans la demeure de campagne de Sacha
Guitry qui pour la première fois est
ouverte au public alors les visiteurs
vont pouvoir découvrir l'exposition
intitulée
plus largement cette exposition est un
hommage à Sacha Guitry que l'on
redécouvre en tant que cinéaste mais
aussi dans sa vie privée alternée dans
ses relations avec les artistes et les
collectionneurs ou encore comme auteur
et acteurs alors cette exposition elle
s'inscrit dans un projet pédagogique qui
est développé par des lycéens pour
l'épreuve du baccalauréat et car les
vacances peuvent aussi être l'occasion
de partager et de s'ouvrir aux autres
une journée sportive et citoyenne
encadrée par les forces de l'ordre et
les pompiers est organisé à Plaisir oui
c'est le dispositif prox aventure qui
revient pour sa quatrième édition alors
les jeunes plaisirs et leurs familles
sont invités à rencontrer les forces de
l'ordre et les pompiers pour un
après-midi dédié au sport et aussi vite
au travers différentes activités le but
c'est de promouvoir le dialogue entre
les citoyens et ses professions à
l'heure où elles sont parfois
confrontées à la défiance de la
population je vous propose de regarder
quelques images qui ont été tournées par
nos équipes en 2019 en proposant ses
activités ludiques les policiers venus
bénévolement sur leur temps libre
espèrent changer leur image auprès du
public on a toujours un peu des
questions drôles par rapport à l'usage
de l'armement en leur explique la
réalité du terrain en fait on est là
pour casser un peu les stéréotypes que
qu'ils peuvent voir dans les différentes
séries policières soit américaines ou
même parfois française un dispositif qui
continue donc de rassembler chaque année
on termine Gabriel avec une sortie
incontournable sur le territoire qui dit
printemps dit retour des grandes heures
des jardins de Versailles et ses
incontournables visites comté depuis le
début du mois vous pouvez en profiter
tous les dimanches oui accompagné de
comédiens et de compteurs découvrez les
célèbres jardins Lenôtre comme vous ne
les avez jamais vu au travers d'un
spectacle vivant alors c'est une balade
hors du temps au travers des jardins qui
vous est proposé retraçant notamment
l'histoire des illustres personnages qui
les ont traversés un moment ludique de
découverte et d'histoire pour mieux
connaître notre patrimoine la visite
elle dure 1h30 elle est accessible aux
enfants de 6 ans à noter que ces visites
ont également lieu pendant les grandes
eaux merci beaucoup Gabriel Gontier
alors comme d'habitude petit tour de
plateau qu'est-ce qui vous tente le plus
dans ces idées de sortie la demeure de
Sacha Guitry qui a pas l'habitude d'être
ouverte à l'année au public donc
pourquoi pas découvrir ce petit jardin
secret
[Rires]
oui on m'avait différent moi ce serait
plutôt la danse au Théâtre de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines voilà voilà
comme ça ça fait des heureux pour tout
le monde direction à présent cerner la
ville au Cabaret du bout des prés les
coulisses
dévoile exit les paillettes et la
musique des intervenants dispensent leur
secret autour des cascades de cinéma
après avoir proposé cette activité lors
des vacances de février le cabaret ouvre
cet animation aux entreprises le
reportage de Mélanie poquet et je viens
le roi et dangereux c'est comme on va
prendre de l'élan si on sera pour qu'on
peut planter son épaule sa tête enfin
voilà c'est vite une dangerosité bien
sûr contrôlée pas encore de films ou de
spectacle à venir mais ces jeunes
découvrent un univers de l'ombre celui
des cascadeurs
allez-y vraiment posez les mains des
coups sans faire mal à sauter sans se
faire mal aussi des roulades des
parcours et plein de trucs sur le cinéma
j'aime bien quand on était sur la scène
et qu'on a sauté et qu'on a fait les
roulades et tout le stage a été imaginé
par le Cabaret du bout des prés avec
valériane l'une des danseuses elle-même
cascadeuses à l'encadrement des
professionnels comme Aurélien duieux il
a exercé sur la série Lupin le film
Athena de Romain gavra ou au bal perdu 2
on voit un peu toutes les parties de la
cascade mais de manière assez basique ce
que l'idée c'est pas de les former à
devenir cascadeur c'est de vraiment
faire un stage d'initiation où il
s'amuse donc on a vu les chorégraphies
de combat on a vu les chutes classiques
au sol et on va voir les chutes de
hauteur tout à l'heure on a vu un peu de
parcours le déplacement etc et surtout
la comédie parce que c'est une des
facettes qui est très importante
sur la tête à genoux
[Musique]
c'est une expérience parce que forcément
on propose souvent des stages de danse
des stages de chant surtout nous au
cabaret mais je trouve que le stage de
cascade c'est très recherché on a
beaucoup de parents qui nous disent mais
c'est génial de faire ça et c'est rare
une vingtaine d'enfants a pu devenir un
cascadeur le temps d'un stage en février
dernier le cabaret organise aujourd'hui
ses journées à la demande à destination
des entreprises pour les enfants les
adolescents mais aussi les adultes
allez on poursuit cette page loisirs
avec le quiz Grégory cadalet vous nous
avez préparé un quiz sur le vélo de Rome
national de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
lieu où nous trouvons absolument je
profite de notre présence ici pour skit
pour vous challenger sur l'écran qui
nous accueille ce vélo drone national
une jeune histoire mais déjà site
olympique dès l'an prochain avec les
Jeux olympiques de Paris 2024 est-ce que
vous êtes prêts
alors les personnes quelques personnes
qui nous regardent mais qui nous
entendent peut-être depuis les stands
peuvent aussi souffler les réponses si
jamais vous les avez vous aussi qui ne
regardez derrière votre poste de
télévision bien sûr devant votre poste
de télévision vous pouvez jouer avec
nous on va faire des teams team Mathilde
Gabriel contre la team Céline Régine on
fait comme ça et si Gabriel vous avez
des réponses je vous tendrai le micro
tout simplement comme ça voilà et vous
soufflerez la réponse alors on va
remonter en arrière plusieurs années de
travaux ont été nécessaires pour voir
sortir de terre cet écran le vélo drone
national c'est 6000 places lieu du siège
de la Fédération Française de Cyclisme
sa piste de BMX juste à côté également
olympique première question tout
simplement en quelle année a été
inauguré ce vélo drone national
en 2014
je sais pas vous aviez vous aviez la
bonne réponse Céline
il a été inauguré en 2014
effectivement 2014 je demandais bien la
date de l'inauguration est très
précisément c'est le 30 janvier 2014
jour de l'inauguration officielle même
si le vélo Drôme avait ouvert ses portes
et le 13 janvier pour l'occasion à un
duel qui n'avait d'amical que le nom à
opposé à la France à la Grande-Bretagne
les Bleus ont remporté l'ensemble des
six épreuves qui étaient proposées ce
soir-là devant un vélo Drôme plein et
François pervy restera jamais dans
l'histoire comme le premier coureur
cycliste français à s'être imposé sur la
piste du vélodrome national lors des JO
de Paris 2024 le vélo de route nationale
faitra donc son 10e anniversaire 1-0
pour la team Mathilde Gabriel alors que
serait le vélo drone national sans sa
piste la piste bien sûr qui fait la
renommée mondiale de ce vélo de national
on va voir quelques images justement de
sa construction nous sommes fin 2013 à
deux mois de l'ouverture du vélo de
route à votre avis combien mesure cette
piste du vélodrome national je demande
la longueur du tour de piste
ah je crois qu'on a des
personnes dans le public qui nous
regardent Grégory qui ont la réponse la
réponse vous l'avez quand même en
plateau non faites des estimations pour
essayer de faire
on peut faire des estimations la
personne qui est le plus proche le
groupe qui est le plus proche remporte
le point sur cette question alors on
avait une proposition dans le public
on a 250 Céline Régine
on va dire de 125 225 Mathilde Gabriel
moi je dirais moi quand même
et bien c'est dans le public que l'on
remporte le bon point et on a un tout
petit le même dans le public c'est
Michael bien sûr journée ce sport de la
rédaction de TV 78 il était un peu
avantage sur cette question et 250
mètres de long 8 mètres de large des
virages qui sont relevés par endroits à
44 degrés ce qui est unique en Europe la
piste du vélodrome et l'oeuvre du de
l'architecte allemand Ralph shurman elle
est faite de bois de pain du bois de
pain venu directement de Sibérie
toujours à 0 pour Mathilde Gabriel fasse
à Céline Régine vous avez l'occasion de
vous refaire sur cette question alors il
y a eu bien sûr de grands moments au
Vélodrome national de 50 ans en Yvelines
le premier d'envergure c'était du 18 au
22 février 2015 les Championnats du
monde de cyclisme sur piste sur vitaminé
à domicile l'équipe de France emmenait
notamment par François pervy et Grégory
Baugé avaient briller combien bien de
médaille d'or avec remporté les Bleus en
2015 Michael il n'a pas le droit de
participer dans le public c'est trop
facile pour lui j'étais en train de le
regarder
pour faire un petit film on va faire des
estimations et enfin le groupe qui est
le plus proche remportera le point
Céline Régine
si médaille 6 médailles d'or pour Céline
et Régine
et bien c'est un 2-0 pour Mathilde et
Gabriel effectivement 5 médailles d'or
alors cette au total si on prend en
compte également les argents et bronze
qui a placé la France en tête de ces
mondiaux de cyclisme sur piste au
classement des nations des titres chez
les hommes en vitesse individuelle par
équipe au kilomètre au Kirin et à
l'américaine et les mondiaux de cyclisme
surpissent sont revenus ici même au vélo
de drone national l'an passé c'était du
13 au 16 octobre cette médaille ont été
également glanées par l'équipe de France
on se souviendra encore de la joie de
mathildegro que vous voyez à l'image ou
encore de Marie divine Kouame en 500 m
contre la montre de quoi bien sûr les 7
grands espoirs en vue des Jeux
olympiques de Paris 2024 une petite
devinette à présent j'étais un cycliste
français dont la renommée est venue sur
le tard moi qui est décroché un titre de
champion du monde de cyclisme sur route
dans la catégorie était plus de 150 oui
je vais bien dire plus de 150 j'ai même
collectionné plusieurs records du monde
dont deux que j'ai établi ici même au
vélo de route nationale de 50 ans en
Yvelines qui était je pense que je parle
d'une personne bien sûr qui est
aujourd'hui décédée alors j'ai
pas s'il a établi ce repas à 102 ans
alors il a établi même deux records à
102 ans c'était dans la catégorie des
plus de 100 ans et à 150 dans la
catégorie qu'il a établi lui-même
catégorie des plus de 150
voilà vous avez pas la réponse
mais je crois qu'on nous souffle la
réponse
Robert Marchand la start-up rdimanager
qui est présent aussi dans le public qui
vit qui a donné la bonne réponse Mickaël
l'avait également Robert Marchand alors
ces médecins disaient de lui justement à
102 ans qui est lavé la santé cardiaque
d'un homme de 50 ans donc c'est-à-dire
l'athlète qu'il était le cycliste a
battu ici même plusieurs records de
l'heure vous le disiez catégorie des
plus de 100 ans catégories également des
plus de 150 donc les deux records c'est
en 2014 et 2017 au cours de sa vie
Robert Marchand a été gymnase de haut
niveau mais aussi pompier de Paris il
s'est éteint le 22 mai 2021 à l'âge de
109 ans c'est un homme fort sympathique
toujours de bonne humeur et un tantinet
blagger quand on avait la chance de lui
tendre notre micro alors dernière
question toujours 2-0 voilà d'ores et
déjà la défaite pour la team Céline
Régine mais vous avez l'occasion
peut-être de marquer un point de sauver
l'honneur dans ce quiz alors le vélo
Drôme ce n'est pas qu'un écrin sportif
d'autres événements ont pu être
accueillis ici bah c'est le cas
aujourd'hui justement
dédié au talent et aux innovations il y
a eu aussi des soirées musicales voilà
pour citer quelques exemples
d'événements qui ont pu être accueillis
ici en plein épidémie de covid-19
souvenez-vous le vélo drone national
c'était transformé en un immense centre
de vaccination ce qui lui avait valu un
surnom comment a été rebaptisé le
vélodrome national de 50 ans en Yvelines
pendant la période du covid 19 on a
peut-être une on leur laisse le dernier
point
le vaccinodrome très bonne réponse pour
le 2-1 alors qui celle d'ores et déjà la
victoire bien sûr de Mathilde et Gabriel
mais en tout cas bien joué Céline bien
joué Régine pour cette bonne réponse
effectivement le vaccinodrome qui a
ouvert un peu plus d'un an sur le
territoire de 50 ans en Yvelines entre
janvier 2021 et février 2022 sur place
plus de 400 000 injections de vaccins
contre le covid 19 ont été réalisés sont
environ 4000 personnes vaccinées ce par
jour dans l'équipe soignante on a
retrouvé 1000 personnes un mobilisées
sur place 500 soyons très précisément
1000 personnes dans l'organisation de ce
au quotidien et donc 500 soignants ce
qui avait permis de tourner quand même
une page et de laisser derrière nous le
covid-19 qui existe toujours mais qu'on
a laissé quand même derrière nous
aujourd'hui merci beaucoup
et Merci à VOUS Gabriel bravo Mathilde
victoire merci
on continue de parler du 7 8 à
l'approche des vacances de printemps
attention si vous avez prévu de prendre
la route ce week-end quels sont les
prévisions biseau Bison Futé de ce
week-end Grégory
alors selon Bison Futé justement les
principales difficultés attendues en
Île-de-France seront pour les journées
de samedi et vendredi et ceux dans le
sens des départs vendredi à
l'Île-de-France est classé orange il
vous est conseillé de quitter ou de
traverser la région avant 14h des
difficultés de circulation sont à
prévoir notamment sur l'autoroute A10 au
niveau des barrières de péage samedi la
circulation la circulation sera
également dense et bison futé et voit
orange également dans le sens des
départs il est préférable de prévoir un
départ de la région avant 8 heures
encore une fois Grégory canalet c'est
bientôt la fin de cette émission mais
juste avant de se quitter je vous
propose de jeter un dernier coup d'oeil
à la météo de demain
demain matin le temps sera nuageux dans
le nord-ouest des Yvelines du côté de
Rambouillet et de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines nous devrions
avoir quelques éclaircisses selon Météo
France au niveau des températures il
fera encore un peu frais le matin
comptez 6 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie et
Versailles 5 degrés à Rambouillet et 4
degrés à Houdan dans l'après-midi le
ciel s'éclaircit sur l'ensemble du
département et côté température comptait
environ 13 à 12 degrés en moyenne et
pour les prévisions météo de ce week-end
dorénavant c'est notre Mister météo
nationale Thomas Fletcher qui vous donne
ses prévisions lui aussi s'est rendu au
Vélodrome national de Saint-Quentin on
Yvelines pour ce nouveau numéro quoi de
beau et la même essayé la piste regardez
[Musique]
alors quoi de beau
et bonjour à tous
allez accélère et alors quoi de beau ce
week-end dans les Yvelines c'est super
compliqué
et la température j'en ai aucune idée
juste ça peut essoufflé donc faut pas
garantir une météo de qualité les
températures montent je l'espère elle
est où l'équipe de France apparemment
c'est pas un vélo électrique
il y a pas d'assistance comment ça
chauffer quand même allez je vais dans
le virage
là je vais choper les cieux je vous
ramène des nuages
heureusement que de vitesse
en tout cas sachez que ça donne chaud
donc on espère qu'il fera de plus en
plus chaud ce weekend
en tout cas ressenti 48
voilà parce que j'ai pas vu l'équipe de
France je les ai fumé
c'est ma conclusion
alors est-ce que vous faites gagner des
cadeaux on a quelques petits goodies à
distribuer en effet vous pouvez
en prendre
merci est-ce qu'il faut que je fasse
quelque chose pour en gagner
est-ce que vous allez bien madame
est-ce qu'on peut les observer s'il vous
plaît regardez moi j'ai déjà gagné un
gros stylo oh la vache avec mon équipe
bonjour l'équipe
je vous laisse il faut que vous tâtiez
le produit quand même je peux envoler un
ou deux ou trois c'est un cadeau oh
merci là par exemple je peux partir avec
là on dira rien prenez pas le sans
contact
attends c'est du vol Airbus
tu as déjà deux stylos
attends il y a un cadeau derrière le
cadeau et il y a un truc derrière là
c'est infini
est-ce que vous faites gagner des trucs
par hasard des petits objets non que
stylo à peine mais rien de plus
mais ils sont carrément beau au stylos
ça il y a pas de problème
si je prends les quatre madame vous
pouvez
non
doubler le quadruplé le
collection et j'ai entamé une belle
collection grâce à vous en plus il y en
a il y en a un avec quatre couleurs dans
un seul quoi
là c'est jackpot le bénef oh là il y a
du match bonjour
c'est quand même un sacré cadeau ça déjà
c'est quoi comme cadeau ah c'est les
bonbons à la menthe je peux vous en
voler un monsieur
bonjour
vous m'intéresse beaucoup les lunettes
aussi et c'est pour mettre
[Musique]
ça c'est classe
on voit bien on voit bien avec la
Société générale il y en a déjà dedans
du gel
ok faut qu'on trouve du gel ça existe ça
mais je la prends en même temps que vous
ok
c'est pas grave c'est tout en fait
[Rires]
le rose ça me va très bien
[Musique]
et voilà merci beaucoup madame ouais
elle est bien là
[Musique]
et justement notre Mister météo
nationale Thomas Fletcher est un plateau
avec nous alors Thomas c'est comment de
faire du vélo sur cette piste du vélo
mais c'est vraiment qui font quoi il y a
pas de boss c'est tout droit c'est cool
vous avez l'air un petit peu fatigué
vraiment pas vraiment
question avec Gabriel combien de stylos
vous avez pu récolter je sais pas si je
peux communiquer ça parce que il en
reste pas mal dans le salon donc ouais
ouais on va dire deux trois même si une
quinzaine quoi au vu des images je pense
pas moi non plus et apparemment il y a
du chocolat aussi Jeff de Bruges là-bas
donc on va faire un petit tour en tout
cas on note bien le stylo qui fait aussi
gel hydroalcooliques ça c'est très
pratique
merci beaucoup Thomas ketchup c'est la
fin de cette émission merci d'avoir été
avec nous depuis le vélodrome national
de 50 ans en Yvelines à l'occasion de
l'événement ski heat le rendez-vous
dédié aux innovations et aux talent je
vous souhaite une belle soirée sur TV 78
prenez soin de vous
[Musique]